hi guys today we're gonna talk about
when to take your vitamins I had this
question come up multiple times when do
I take supplements and so I just gonna
I'm just going to create this video to
explain when to take them it's kind of a
minor point when to take them it's not a
major thing except for a couple little
things they'll still work but this will
help optimize it a little bit and by the
way when you're taking supplements it's
not gonna affect your ketosis it's not
going to break in a minute fasting okay
as an FYI so I just did two videos and
one by the way okay vitamin b-complex or
about them and see you can take that any
time these are mainly water soluble
except for like the fat soluble be one
that's called benfotiamine
you'd want to take that with food or fat
to help it be absorbed and then you have
a fat soluble vitamins like vitamin A D
and K or K 2 these are better digested
with food or fat but let's say for
example in the morning you have the
bulletproof coffee you have a little fat
in your coffee well you can definitely
take these then because that fat will
help the absorption okay and by the way
when you're taking d3 in k2 to remove
excess calcium from the body whether it
is a kitty stone or calcium in the
arteries or calcium in the joint or
whatever you don't want to be taking
dairy with that okay so you want to
eliminate dairy because you don't want
that extra calcium you want to kind of
create a void of calcium so this will
just suck it right out of this soft
tissue alright now when dealing with the
stomach you have various things you have
stomach acidifier is pertain how to
chloride you have upset a vinegar pills
for example take those just before the
meal now if you're taking upset of
vinegar in a liquid with water you can
pretty much just take that any time it's
not going to be an issue but if you're
taking concentrated pills take it just
before you eat if you're taking enzymes
just before you eat if you're taking
purified bile salts because the gall
bladder needs support I would recommend
taking that after because this is
alkaline so if we take this
before we kind of neutralize or decrease
the stomach acids we don't want to do
that after before before now if you're
taking a greens product you know a lot
of people take these in the morning
that's totally fine if you want to try
and experiment and get a little more
absorption out of that you can take that
with a meal or even around your
bulletproof coffee because you have some
fat in there
one of the main phytonutrients
carotenoids is fat soluble and
chlorophyll is fat soluble as well so if
you add a little fat or take this with a
meal you can extract more of those
phytonutrients from that it's a minor
point but I just wanted to bring it up
okay
herbs there's a lot of different herbal
remedies you can take those anytime tea
could take it any time herbal tea
electrolytes they work a little better
on empty stomach because you have more
acid minerals need acid to absorb so
anytime you're taking a like calcium
carbonate for example which is alkaline
that's going to take the acid out of the
body so you wouldn't want to take your
calcium or I'm not recommending taking
calcium carbonate but you wouldn't want
to take calcium in general right before
a meal because you'll dilute the stomach
acid so if you're taking calcium take it
right before going to bed okay but
electrolytes empty stomach works great
but again if you want to take before
your meals go for it it's going to be a
minor point it's really mainly for those
people that don't have enough stomach
acid and they can have a problem
absorbing that as well probiotic okay
you want to take your probiotics right
before bed oh and I did forget about one
supplement called EDTA it's a key later
or if you're taking ip6 it's another key
later when you're taking key laterz you
want to take those on an empty stomach
you don't want to take minerals with
them okay so wait an hour and a half
before you take a key later as far as
eating goes or taking any of those
supplements and then don't take your
mineral supplements for an hour and a
half let that key later go through and
pull out whatever you're trying to pull
out like heavy metals or iron and then
you can take the minerals that you want
and put those bit back in at other time
so
empty stomach on the key litters alright
guys thanks for watching
hey guys real quick I have a new healthy
keto eating plan for you just go to dr.
Berg comm it's right on the front page I
put a link down below download it it's
free check it out